[Music]
this is your weather now heat warnings
already in effect
all the way until saturday now at 9 00
pm look it encompasses
all parts of the region here all the way
to california and also into arizona this
is for areas below 4 000 feet because
in the mountains there's also a heat
advisory so not much relief for the
mountains either that goes into effect
tomorrow
and lasts all the way into 9 p.m
saturday tune in includes central nye
county too a red flag warning in effect
at this hour for the mountains
nye and lincoln county with good reason
we have two fires currently burning
right now
around state route 160 in the spring
mountains currently outside it is hot
108 in las vegas
111 for you in north las vegas 110 for
nellis 108 for henderson two and look at
that
we do have gusty winds outside at this
hour your night planner shows clouds
increasing this evening
those winds will decrease more but it's
still going to be hot tonight 101 and 9
p.m
eight news now at 11 we'll be at 94
degrees we'll start the morning
in those 80s we'll break records this
week for daytime highs
and warm lows even i'll show you all
those numbers
and more all coming up your most
accurate forecast but first
here's your news at 5.